Надворі плюс 35,
а вони завзято працюють.
Це не фермери, це - звичайні німці.
Менеджери, інженери, водії.
Замість того, аби піти у прохолодний супермаркет
і купити полуницю там,
вони збирають її самотужки на фермерських полях.
Це надзвичайно популярне заняття в Німеччині.
Втім, багато хто приходить сюди не стільки заради ягід,
скільки заради процесу. Зазвичай із собою беруть дітлахів.
Тут полуниця натуральна.
І це задоволення для дітей,
адже такого немає ані в школі, ані в садку вдома.
Це таке задоволення!
Звісно, можна купити полуницю у супермаркеті,
але це не то. Особлива насолода - збирати самій!
Багато хто приїздить сюди по кілька разів на тиждень.
На вихідних може зібратися до двох тисяч людей.
На полі можна перебувати хоч цілий день, це безкоштовно.
А от за зібраний врожай доведеться заплатити на касі.
Втім, збирачі кажуть, що ягоди тут набагато дешевші,
ніж у супермаркетах, в середньому - на 30-50%.
Ми контролюємо, щоб нічого не крали.
Ми площу у 30-35 гектарів обнесли парканом,
люди можуть вільно пересуватися на цій території.
У середньому 8-10 наших співробітників ходять і перевіряють,
щоб не занадто пошкоджували дерева
та не витоптували багато кущів полуниці.
І загалом вони дивляться за тим, щоб усе було добре.
Цей бізнес, розповідає Нільс,
його родина розпочала 15 років тому,
згодом до полуниці додалися малина,
вишні, черешні, яблука та овочі -
загалом 30 різноманітних культур.
Збирають врожай, зазвичай, саме гості.
Це для власників вигідніше, аніж утримувати працівників.
До кінця сезону фруктів  на кущах та деревах не лишається - їх повністю обривають.